he's portrayed himself as a military
strong man who can unite libya after
years of conflict
but khalifa hafter has taken off his
military uniform and announced his bid
to become libya's first democratically
elected president
elections will be the best way and best
path for libya to get back its place
amongst the countries of the world i
declare myself a nominee for the
presidential elections not seeking power
not finding a place but to lead our
people towards a better future and
towards welfare
in april
2019 haftard led a 14-month military
offensive to seize tripoli from the
internationally recognized government
hundreds of thousands of people were
displaced and the city's infrastructure
damaged
he's been widely accused of committing
war crimes
libya has africa's largest oil reserves
but since the revolution that toppled
long-time leader muammar gaddafi in 2011
the country has been politically divided
and engulfed in violence
ten years on from the revolution seifin
islam gaddafi walmart's second son has
re-emerged on the libyan political scene
and on sunday he applied to register as
a presidential candidate
safe is wanted by the international
criminal court for crimes against
humanity including attacks on civilians
and peaceful protesters
presidential elections are scheduled for
next month but libya's rival legislative
houses have yet to agree on a
constitutional framework to hold the
vote and the election commission is
accused of helping certain candidates an
allegation it denies
we completely reject the candidacy of
criminals like safe gaddafi and khalifa
in the upcoming elections we call on the
electoral commission to reject the
applications of any criminals we hold
them legally responsible
some officials agree
the libyan people will only be satisfied
when they choose who they want to rule
them through elections they will never
concede the right to vote but they came
out with laws tailored for certain
individuals and we will never accept
that
less than six weeks before scheduled
nationwide elections libya is still
deeply divided and despite international
pressure many are concerned the vote may
be delayed
malik trainer al jazeera